oh I love it
Megan Fox and Machine Gun Kelly putting
in the work to keep their twin flames
burning on the first day you told me I
was your twin flame from a past life and
tonight the moon is full so take me
anywhere outside a store sells E.T Megan
and MGK are doing so much better they
have been working on having very healthy
and fluid communication and they have
also been seeking therapy which has
helped save their relationship we've
found a therapist that really works for
us couples and individually and it's
definitely a process it's not an easy
one some of some of it's really
difficult but
our therapist said that a relationship
is basically the process of breaking
each other down but most people don't
have the tools to build each other back
up to rebuild the source adds they have
learned that honesty and trust are the
key pillars to any relationship MGK has
been making a huge effort to ensure
their relationship is in a good place
and that Megan is happy
but what about the wedding well
according to our source their engagement
status and wedding planning is a work in
progress at this time but they are both
confident that they will be together
forever their goal is to have a happy
honest loving passionate relationship
that they are both committed to love is
probably the biggest project I've ever
worked on yeah so yeah everything
encompassing that I put you know I I
give that more energy than I give my
work so Megan and MGK first got engaged
in January 2022 but after a year of red
carpet PDA the couple hit a rough spot
in early 2023 when MGK was accused of
infidelity and some even speculated that
they had split but an April source told
E.T the couple was taking things day by
day it's a constant process of like
suffering and passion and love and we're
just learning that and navigating that
and doing that together and in May MGK
supported Megan at a Sports Illustrated
event and just last week the two were
spotted holding hands while leaving a
London hotel so while nothing is certain
things seem to be going well for the
couple sticking with the journey and
crossing fingers and hoping
[Music]
foreign